[Musik]
hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ried bereits im titel eingeblendet
das heutige video etwas mit einem
gamepad zu tun und zwar mit sicherheit
habe ja auch einen drescher kolorit
erdlöcher skateboard main gebiet und ich
habe viele kommentare bekommen von wegen
haye und darf uns nicht fragen bist du
überhaupt kennen skater und so deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht wir ändern das mag
heute aus diesem grund habe ich nicht
dafür amazon bestellt doch dass ich sehr
lange warten musste weil frauchen buch
du geliefert wurde das problem war auch
wer kein narr mit dem ihr bruder max und
ich versuchen dieses video wird zwei
jahren drei jahre bei 3 jahren versuchen
wir das video jetzt rekord und jetzt
endlich der moment kommen ich habe mir
im skateboarden
der prozess steht erstmal an
also wenn jetzt zb wenn ich merke man
das gut sagt der zürcher florian habe
leute dann würde ich da anfangen direkt
an mit dem auspacken von denen geht das
absolute skateboards zeit für die
absoluten profi trader von orad
inklusivvolumen meine damen und herren
ich würde sagen das ganze thema autismus
den bergen hatte früher in der in der im
gymnasium fordert an der stelle ist ein
kollege von mir früher und er hat
unterricht mit dem geld was hier um
gespielt als ich weiß wie man von sitzen
damit fahren kann und man muss quasi so
vorgehen dass man ihn nicht so drauf hat
nicht einfach aber ich halte nicht warum
jetzt
machte man sich da sehr hart vorbereitet
video aufnehmen
du schläfst hier und lässt du hier muss
sich erholen vermuten damit ich finde
das etwas wir haben das spiel aus
dreierwette preisgeld bord ein paar
rollen junge wir haben oder diese
verstellt teile ich würde sagen gefangen
erstmal mit dem ersten box natürlich das
wort wo man dort steht sogar dieses deck
oben und normal alter ich habe komplett
glaube ich irgendwie 13 euro bezahlt
oder so das geht voll klage wird
überlegt sandwiches bin auch ab genauso
wie golfen der dinge drehen kann also
hier besser skateboard das heißt und her
eigentlich nur den einen finger ewige
out of hell und in anderen so mitten in
die mitte man hat es nicht nur am
nachmittag richte die tricks machen kann
ich glaube ich konnte den medien früher
hatte war mit dem breiter wäre gut
ich habe mir auch gefällt das liegt
daran dass wir am falschen städtisches
grün ist das geld ist und ob man
wirklich mit dem skateboard teilen ihnen
wie immer zusammen fahren so kriegs
machen
das basic floss geld wahrscheinlich
einfach dass man fahren kann und ich
würde sagen würden trainiert machen kann
ist partner liegt anderswo lange sitzen
bist du noch nie geschafft
[Musik]
wir kriegen
wow wird wahrscheinlich beim finger
drauf dann müssen oder auch noch mit
drei beinen normal zeigen also
weitergeleitet wird
[Applaus]
die wir gern eine ahnung haben keine
ahnung also ich würde aber sagen freunde
darüber jetzt taktik könnte ich gleich
noch mal frei kein zufall das integrale
hingekriegt habe du bist auf die andere
kiste luca bleibt nur ganz normal
anbieten fragt runter auf die couch
entlang der couch und wieder zurück auf
den zwischen danach dem flicken glocke
über ihre kiste kein problem für mich
ich bin auch ich mache
wenn sie jetzt im wechsel von hier über
auf den strand mitten im rhein man im
schrank
über die band das tor nicht glück für
die gäste da kann nicht jeder so
anspringen
[Applaus]
keine andere 6 3 in die beantworten und
hier ist durch den achsen schlüssel und
neureuther weit stimmt daran gelegen
versucht ihren berg aus und braucht ihre
komplette vor auch mit dem loch blau und
fehler machen
die sache ist ich glaube wir können das
ding nicht komplett nach bauen weil wir
keine achsen haben die mit mir jetzt mal
ganz kurz sagen herzlich wenig dass wir
gerade mache mich natürlich nicht
geklappt hat kommentieren konzentrieren
kann weil ich dann sehr professionelles
cad- auseinanderschrauben zusammen
das mag das ist an der stelle einfach
mal die kommentare ihrer immobilie view
charakter ab braucht es löst sich
langsam aber sicher ist es ein sehr
großes gefühl gefragt das so richtig
dafür dieses gelbe stück abfall energie
ist die heutige frau mögen sich nicht
heute werden kann wird man wieder so
leicht zusammen bauen aber trotzdem noch
die rolle neben wechseln wird kommen
gleich den neuen features bei der 3000
sind ja es sind die regelmäßigkeit würde
sich unter anderem als sponsor habe ein
junger mann sagt immer ich schreibe also
die erste achse haben jetzt schon dran
wir leben hier kurz überprüft ob wir das
einigermaßen gefällt ist doch logisch
man ich bin ein professionelles geht
auseinander und zusammenbauen und auch
professionell das geht ja mal mehr räder
gestellte fragen ihrer klaren und jetzt
kommen wir zum entscheidenden moment das
ist immer so ein bisschen feiner bei der
gelbe riese lust drauf dann packen
getroffen er befindet sich auch wieder
drauf wären das noch getroffen wieder
ein gelber richtung zu singen und jetzt
wieder eine mutter das den effekt aber
auch nicht weil wir wollen ja noch
kurven fahren können
ich brauchte die ganze zeit ich habe
mich voll verletzten können weitergehen
werden gebäude und mutter um liga tief
ich habe die sicherheit kann ich weiß
nicht ob ich die überhaupt noch leute
das ist die letzte aktion gerade in
einer hand abgefertigt worden und dann
noch meine parcours hinzukriegen die
mutter befindet sich auf der aktivseite
schrauben wieder genauso fest die auf
der anderen seite dass er immer noch ein
bisschen nervös habe ich doch defizit
von 5 3
so werden die achse nämlich ist ein
bisschen leichter eingestellt er als bei
den anderen worten jetzt das doch
während jemand wird wirklich vermissen
die kurven leben
trete ich als professor gates zusammen
schrauber und dann bauer weiß natürlich
dass eine organisation und eine
instandhaltung der materialien von
äußerster bedeutung ist aber wisse nicht
was ihr perfekt ja aber ehrlich ich
kenne das aus der vergangenheit vor ort
haben damals antworten dann haben wir
halt nicht alles eingebaut werden was
zusammen wir sind die ganze zeit sind
zusagen über die sicherheit wurde kommt
natürlich auch da hätten wir noch die
verpackungen und jetzt ein bisschen vor
allem die polizei schon an
ja das ist so wie vor werde auf direktem
wege schon erklärt wortmann auch fakt
diesem kapitel ii derzeit achter werden
erste kurzgeschichte aus weil ich nicht
was ich machen konnte fahnen mit dem
finger hinten auf
wo und wann jemand wirklich gelandet
ich freue mich dass wir heute eine
eingeblendete braucht ihr könnt main
kanal abonnieren darum nicht eingesehen
und hier unten zum beispiel video
verlinkt ich hoffe ihr versteht ja alles
nur zu machen brauchen uns war allen
abgefallen
nein video verbreitet